how's it going bros my name is pierre ha
oh boy oh boy what a week it has been I
was in LA for a week I didn't vlog it
but I thought I'll do a little bit of
montage I've seen how the youtubers do
it and I can do it too so basically I
flew to LA to promote my show scare
PewDiePie it's finally out I'll leave a
link to it in the description check it
out we decided to make episode 7 for
free for everyone and watch so episode 1
and 7 are available right now if you ask
me episode 1 and 7 are like by far the
worst episode not sure if I'm allowed to
say that but you bros really seem yet
like you love it already but it gets a
lot better and there's so many moments
where I watched it again and I'm crying
because it's so funny and I'm I'm really
excited for you bros to see it I want to
talk more about YouTube red in the show
later
so just wait a little bit so basically
to promote the show I was on Conan which
was surreal and I think if you watch the
clip of me being on Conan you can tell
because I'm literally just sitting like
the [ __ ] am i doing on Conan Conan and
Andy for that matter are just such great
comedians that I really look up to but
being on Conan was so cool I got to wear
a suit I look pretty good I also got a
chance to have some fun with friends we
met up hangout a Disneyland super fun
stealing vlog footage from Ken fun to
meet some new people as well also worked
on some rebel mode stuff I got no real
updates there but 2016 should be an
exciting year there was nothing sexual
about that I'm so sorry
but either way after Conan I flew to New
York to be on the Today Show and if you
know what the Today Show is you're
probably a mom they said the opposite
thing about me so it's okay he's one of
the biggest stars in the world and trust
us if you haven't heard of him yet your
kids have I don't know why we promoted
to moms I don't know why but it wasn't
that exciting but I think I did a lot
better than Conan but basically while I
was waiting in the backstage in the
green room I'm all these celebrities
just
started popping in and then Ryan
Reynolds came in who's doing to promote
Deadpool and we make eye contact and I'm
just like sup not to be like casual or
cool about it I just imagine like hey
we're we know each other right it's just
so painful but he was super nice he came
up and shook my hand and we talked to
bed I told him I was excited by Deadpool
this is really weird to meet all these
people I had never thought I'd meet
continuing on that I also while I was in
LA got to meet an idol of mine which is
Trey Parker from South Park walking into
the South Park studios in a minute he
excited I'm so nervous
yes yeah II feel my belly yeah I always
loved South Park I loved it as a kid
because it had fart jokes and I loved it
as an adult because it has fart jokes
stop break it's been a huge inspiration
I think you noticed that while watching
some of my videos as well honestly like
meeting Conan and meaning Trey Parker
was a very humbling experience I think
because I realized looking back when I
started making videos in Sweden in my
own little shitty flat to where I was
then you know meeting these people that
I really could look up to and I never
thought I would meet I realized how far
we've come
I it's just incredible I used to be such
a shy and insecure kid and I've improved
so much since then since I started
making videos but also meeting them made
me realize that I've come really far but
there's still a lot more for me to go so
the last thing I wanted to talk about is
scare PewDiePie there's been not a lot
but a few misunderstandings about the
show which I finally realized why and I
think here's what I think is the problem
you go to my videos and then you see
that you have to pay to watch an episode
for scare PewDiePie it costs money to
watch one of my videos that is not the
case though scary PewDiePie is in
addition to what I already do and if you
want to check it out support supported
watch something that I made that is
higher production then it's there and
you can enjoy it just to be 100% clear
I will never charge for my own videos
the ones I create and I think that's
what people think that I'm doing didn't
scare PewDiePie for me it's like I just
love doing these things it was so much
fun to shoot this show and if you bros
can support that I'm just very happy and
grateful because I you bros support
means so much to me I don't think you
realized it really does I'm not just
saying it to be one of those [ __ ] like
mopey ass channels that everyone relates
to sorry don't know why I had to go
there that was my week in LA I had a
blast and I'm excited to be back and
making more videos for you bros thank
you both so much and as always stay
awesome press